I guess the audition process to any
phone is quite daunting yeah because you
get three scenes to really showcase all
your talent and all your passionate to
the character
hey everybody awesome news they finally
cast Nightwing on the Titans TV series
so this is gonna be a breakdown of that
they have a new synopsis Geoff Johns
read like a big long quote about it and
we found out about three other new big
characters from the comics that they're
gonna introduce in addition to the core
titans characters that we already know
about sans Beast Boy we still don't know
who's playing him so I'll say new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
important stuff first the person who's
playing Nightwing Dick Grayson is
Brenton Thwaites now there's a couple
important things in these news releases
that you may have noticed you've
probably seen a bunch of them with
pictures of Robin most of them only
mentioned him as Dick Grayson they don't
specify who he's going to be on the TV
show and I think there's an important
reason for that where Geoff Johns says
and I'm quoting him Dick Grayson is one
of the most important and iconic heroes
in the DC Universe and it wasn't easy to
find him but we have Brenton has the
emotional depth heart danger and
physical presence of Batman's former
protege in the Titans future leader
we're extremely lucky he's chosen to
bring his talents to this project and
this character so you may have noticed
some of the language that he used when
he was describing the character Titans
future leader so some added context if
you haven't seen my other Titans videos
that I've done so far the character is
actually going to be a police officer
working at a police station that's who
they were casting for someone who could
be a cop and play Nightwing at the same
time so you may know that there's an arc
from the comics where Nightwing goes to
be a police officer in Bludhaven
so that's probably where the series is
gonna take place they haven't officially
confirmed that but when you hear about
the other new character they're casting
it'll basically confirms that it's gonna
be the blood Haven Police Department the
series is probably gonna pick up when
he's stopped being Robin and he's gone
back to blüdhaven to try and make his
own way try to kind of figure things out
on his own but before he has taken the
Nightwing mantle in the story of season
1 in addition to whichever villains they
choose to introduce will be the story of
the Titans coming together obviously
have to do that because they all meet
for the first time in the first episode
so it sounds like they have some big
central mystery that brings them
together and then at some point they
officially start working together as a
team so think of daredevil season 1 in
the way that the costume evolved over
that so he got to the comic book costume
by the end of the series we'll probably
see a version of that with the Nightwing
character where he's not Robin but he's
not quite Nightwing yet it through the
course of their adventures in season 1
he takes the mantle but they haven't
confirmed what the costumes are gonna
look like they haven't showed any of
that off they just announced who the
actors are so now we know Nightwing
Raven in Starfire but we still don't
know who Beast Boy is so he's just the
last piece of the puzzle they're
supposed to start shooting in September
so that's probably why they made this
announcement now as far as the actor for
Nightwing I'm totally cool I think he'll
be fine
the people that are casting this TV show
are the same people that cast all the
other Berlin TV shows if they have a
proven track record of finding really
great actors so I think the fact that
they made this specific choice for the
character I think whatever they saw him
do whatever it's gonna look like when we
actually see episodes I think it'll
totally be fine but it's just you know
sort of a confirmation that this is
gonna take place in and around blüdhaven
there are three new characters that
they're casting we found out that
they're casting Hawk and Dove
so it says recurring female graceful
master fighting machine she straddles
the world of being a thrill-seeking and
do-gooding vigilante along with being
her crime-fighting partners emotional
anchor in Caregiver she loves him but
fears what he may become so the whole
idea is that Hawk and Dove are sort of
this codependent relationship baggage is
off the chain crazytown banana pants so
she usually winds up having to talk him
down from stabbing everybody to death
criminals or friends so here's a really
cool thing the rumor is is that they're
actually looking to cast Alan Ritchson
who you'll remember from Smallville and
Rebecca Rittenhouse for those roles so I
actually think that'd be a pretty solid
casting for rock it would let him be
super crazy but I don't know how big
those characters will be if they'll just
be recurring or they'll be guest stars
there's only supposed to be about 13
episodes in the first season so we'll
see how much they show up but it just
confirms that there's going to be a lot
of other DC comic book characters
popping up
so the last new person sort of
confirming blüdhaven Police Department
is actually supporting female she's a
detective alongside Dick Grayson who
knows more than she lets on pretty has
tattoos so they're talking about a mere
Orbach who's right out of the comics she
works with Dick Grayson as a police
detective as it applies as a partner in
Bludhaven so when that casting
description reads knows more than she
lets on it's probably just her knowing
exactly what's going on with Dick
Grayson like I know you used to be the
Robin it will probably know that he's
also fighting crime as a vigilante when
he's not working as a police detective
during the day so detective is sort of
his day job nighttime is vigilante
Nightwing stuff so let me know in the
comments you know based on all these
characters what are you most excited for
and what do you think his costumes gonna
look like because no matter how hardcore
your series is at some point when a
superhero takes a new mantle you have to
have that funny montage with the costume
I'm really crossing my fingers that they
have some disco Nightwing costume jokes
because you may have seen that Judas
contract movie they released earlier
this year in the comics that was
actually the first arc where he debuted
that Nightwing costume like he stepped
out and was like this is my new moniker
everybody called me Nightwing this is
what my costume is gonna look like so
whichever version of the costume is your
favorite obviously it'll be more
modernized in the way that the other DC
TV shows have modernized those Heroes
costumes but the really cool thing about
night wings modern costume right now the
blue one is that it actually looks
pretty legit like he could walk out in
the day and people wouldn't laugh at him
it's not like Green Arrow walking around
in a Robin Hood costume from the comics
so if you're not already a crazy
hardcore Nightwing comic-book fan and
you want to start reading stuff to get
ready I would recommend you start with
the rebirth but if you want to get
really specific but like I refer to the
comic book arc where he goes back to
blüdhaven to be a police detective for a
little while that's during vol 2 so you
can read all of vol 2 and if you really
want to go back for a deep cut you can
read Nightwing vol 1 that's his very
first solo series ever it's only four
issues long boy you two ran for a couple
hundred issues including big crossover
titles so there's like a whole bunch of
stuff during vol 2 so you can pick from
any of those to check it out just to
learn about what
even feels like if you haven't seen it
before in the comics and what the
character is like the really quick
takeaway is that he's like a more fun
version of Batman that smiles a lot more
tells jokes has more interpersonal
relationships Batman has a lot of ladies
that he gets with in the comics I mean
it's with Selina Kyle right now but
Nightwing is just a little bit more of a
charmer with the ladies so just a lot of
his dialogue reflects that so I think
they'll have a lot of fun with that on
the TV show but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner DeMarcus means
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what will probably
happen is when they start filming this
in September while they're dropping
trailers for all the other DC TV shows
I'll do behind the scenes videos for
Titans because I'm not expecting a
trailer for that at least until December
it's gonna take them a while to start
filming and getting through stuff then
they'll start dropping promos so no
confirm release date for that yet either
but as soon as they start dropping
information of course I'll do videos for
it so while you wait for everything you
can click here for the new flash season
4 preview they just dropped and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight